it's time for drew's news your daily
tute on the good news horn and with me
at the desk is my favorite bugle boy
rossi ross matthew
hi
hi everybody
toot your tutor
um okay first up while we orchestrate
our massive makeover today newsweek
reports one woman bravely recruited all
of tick-tock to revamp her look okay she
is brave that is brave yes her name is
alessandra
uh and she posted this before look and
then asked ginzie to give her some
constructive criticism and they sure did
she got shorted and they always do
and um for better or worse she got tons
of comments and some said ditch that
side part um and some said to lighten up
the eye makeup for a fresher look while
alessandra took it all to heart and
posted this transformation wow
i think she looks phenomenal right um
but i would never do this in a million
years
ross matthews is tapping out i
i if i ask you how i look you know do
you like how i look what i'm really
saying is can you confirm that i think
that i look good
you know so the fact that she went on
social media hey strangers give me your
two cents
not gonna happen
uh
are you are stronger and braver than i
am all right for those who like the
middle part raise your flower green give
me green
oh whoa so much green
okay
you guys i hate to disagree but i kind
of love the side part i do too what i
really love is the fresh makeup yeah i
think that's the real game changer all
right next we got some style news some
old footwear is making a big time
comeback and it's it's not just for
milkmaids anymore
pop sugar reports you know clogs well
they're clogging on back they say people
are going to be clogging hither and
tether this fall
here in the audience they don't know
clogs are not for everyone drew
uh i have to ask you are you a clogger
i do not have the leg for a clog a clog
does not look like a clog on me it looks
like a hoof
i'm not kidding listen i know my body i
know tailoring yeah and clogs are not
flattering on me well you know what i
got into this summer and i can't even
believe i'm gonna admit this on uh but
ross matthews got into um crocs this
summer yeah
i know i was near the pool i went to the
mall one day and i was like that's kind
of cute they put these little things on
so i thought no one will ever know just
buy a pair
gibbons and then i was rocking out with
my crocs out all summer long
and now look clogs are a whole trend so
did i start it am i a hero i don't know
you tell me
green flowers for in with the clog red
for out with the clog let's see what you
guys think
a lot of mixed surprisingly more green
than i would have thought um well go
clogs i love that we're really debating
the issues the nation needs to talk
about
thank you for this listen we talk about
it all on the news and next we're always
ready to turn this desk into a lab today
we're trying the latest skin care trend
glamour reports that the frozen cucumber
trick is going viral and dermatologists
say they might have something to this
cute are loaded
with vitamin k can reduce puffiness and
help with acne and dark circles so we
have frozen cucumbers here these are
legit so cold that we wrapped a towel
around them and i just rub this all over
my face
that's the that's the um suggestion
okay but guess what
what we have someone in our audience
who's gonna do this with us hi who's
this hi oh it's kat ladies and gentlemen
hi camera warm welcome
are we gonna really do this on
television i'm ready kat i would like
you to lead this beauty session
i'm going to start at the eye area
because that feels
more appropriate okay
oh my god that's so cold wow smells
nice it does feel like like a like a
real product that you'd buy at a store
though
you know a grocery store
like one of those roller things
i'd like to know um what your thoughts
are yay or nay to the cucumber i feel
refreshed i'm i say yay yeah i don't
know that i'm sold i think
i think i'm good i smell like a salad i
think i'm good
i just like getting to do that with you
cat thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
and
before we go i wanted to share a
powerful image by photographer ellie
sharp it's a really good reminder that
social media is a veneer it is a slice
it's just not the whole apple and we are
doing a beauty show today
but one of the things that i really
really really can't press upon enough
i just think that beauty is a spiritual
and an emotional journey as well as the
way it looks and social media can really
play a lot of tricks on us this is who
we are this is what we've got to work
with and we need to feel good about it
and be kind to ourselves as well in the
process
well said
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what else is beautiful ross
what you
well girl it's the cucumber you got to
try it
so is cat and it ain't the cucumber
thank you
[Music]